I did your love for the Biebs starts um
you know what it started when I was like
12 I believe and that was like right
before he retired turns out Billy
eyelashes love for Justin Bieber growing
up was a whole lot more intense than we
knew you know I just want to say that I
do we did consider taking you to therapy
for how incredibly you were in so much
pain yeah we learned about it all during
the latest episode of Billy's me and dad
radio show including just how much she
loved the Biebs his video for as long as
he loved me I would watch the music
video for this song and just sob
but I just happen to remember this one
really well in the video and really
talking to me about it being excited
that was coming out and just crying and
crying and everyone knows the whole
Billy Justin Bieber thing but this song
was a big part of it what did you have
posters in your room I did yeah big ass
if you have so many celebrity fans Julia
Roberts hailey Bieber just posted about
you is anyone sliding into those DMS yet
I mean Bieber did What did he say
you have to see you'll have to see you
know one day you'll find out but that
was crazy
um the thing that he actually know the
first thing he sent was a screenshot of
a DM I sent him in 2040 stop so he
remembered from 23 didn't remember it
but you know when you follow somebody
yeah you can see everything they've DM
do in the past right so when he started
following you he got the notification
yeah do for your hearts it like felt
good and that felt bad at the same thing
yeah but it was amazing he's he's so
sweet like I feel I just honestly I feel
for him man he's he's got the public I
do good hard to believe that interview
was just over a year ago and since then
Justin hopped on a remix of Billy's bad
guy from the bad guy
[Music]
Bieber isn't the only thing Billy got
emotional over though during her early
teenage years but she's overcome a lot
of her tearful triggers where there was
a period of time where I cried every day
of my life
like when I was like 13 14 15 every
single day I was real hard years yeah
16 as well and I don't know 17 18 I
really did not cry barely at all I am
proud to say that I barely cry anymore
and one thing I've overcome dad yeah
this is a big deal it's a big yeah not
that it's wrong to cry but it's good
that I feel you don't feel like I don't
kind of like I want to cry anymore
[Music]